what's going on everybody my name is
Silva Luke you from Miami Florida wise
wise wise and you are now listening to
the Monday to Monday playlist but my man
Gary Vee and my boy
yeah good to see ya good to see you well
fantastic good man absolutely yeah so
shopping how are you man they're gonna
see man they see hey Ben good I would
you something oh well I've been well so
just lay out there huh yeah wow it's
special outside it is special yeah but
yeah so they're in town he leaves
tomorrow if this is so I'll show
knowledge so I'll show me but uh how was
it it's fantastical it's a definitely
one of those moments that culminate we a
career combination to like that place
yeah a lot of our we're just really
grateful taking dollar
how long were two shows um I believe New
York shows about an hour and 15 for my
set so overall two hours
same thing for LA as well maybe a little
bit longer LA a little bit more lead
time so it was great right good for you
man thank you so much yeah I think we
jump right into it but one thing is so
interesting the reason why this week so
important is like he has a song empathy
cream gratitude so self dismissed but I
think it's so unlike for Gary says about
you gonna cut out your loser friend you
gotta like yeah you gotta be selfish you
know I mean to be selfish struggle with
it yeah after all are you ready now I
mean um I still it's it's still
something I struggle with I don't think
you ever completely stop having those
moments right because you know you're a
caring person so you genuinely are gonna
go through it from time after time I
think it's just becoming cognitive of it
conscious of it so that you can see when
it's happening so I've got a line I've
gotten a lot better at it just in terms
of taking time for myself and making
sure that I can feel my
but I think it's something that ever
goes away just become conscious
something to do better at it step by
step by step when it's your demeanor
right like either either you're giving
energy or taking energy southern
thinking a lot it's actually really
funny we're having this conversation I
thought about a lot this morning when I
was working out on the way into work
it's like my natural default is to give
it's why so much good has happened but
there's always a breaking point yeah
that's right you know and you know
there's a couple different relationships
right now where I'm just like [ __ ] like
they're about to walk into a buzzsaw
because I haven't given them any
indication like that's the one thing I
want to do a better job of I feel like I
you know I don't want to just default
into I'm a good person and I'm like and
then just you know one of the things I'm
most embarrassed of ever is when I was a
teenager in my early 20s the way I would
break up with a girl was so
disrespectful and not like just like
genuinely not a man about it yeah you
know I would just disappear and it was
easy before with no technology but at
the same token it would have meant that
I would have been absolutely that person
that just like everything was great for
nine months and then I would just text
and be like I'm out right so like I
don't judge people for a period because
I think it's a bad idea but like I think
the thing that I'm constantly even at 42
I'm like I've got to do a better job I'm
doing a way but I'm not anywhere close
to that version but more indicators
along the way of like this isn't cool or
like this isn't right yeah so that it's
not just like like [ __ ] you this is over
like you know like what does that like
pigs get that hogs get slaughtered or
something you know like my natural
demeanors to give so much that the other
person is even realize that they're
becoming a hog yeah I can understand
that too because especially from the
especially from like the value that you
place on it it's like when you're giving
and giving and giving in your mind it's
like you know this is what this is what
I'm outputting this is what my
energy is for and rightfully so you do
it from the bottom of your heart so
doesn't matter what happens where the
heretic rip stands you know when you're
giving something it's genuinely because
you want to but at the same time you
just like you know with something or
certain situations are happening like
this isn't cool and it did for me I've
been one of those guys where you know
sometimes I'll just internalize things
and then when I'm ready I'm ready and I
won't realize that nobody else has been
prepared or it's kind of like a like a
blindside yeah it's an emotional
strength that um that you know your gift
is your curse so I listen I wouldn't
trade it for anything
borås you know you know I wouldn't trade
it for anything but I I want to be more
conscious of it because you know even
from vaynermedia as a 850 person company
you know 18 months ago I woke up I'm
like my company's entitled Wow you know
I'm thinking about my kids I'm like
they're gonna be entitled like
emotionally it's emotional you know it's
you know and you know like my couple
Mike my family breaks if my mom or I are
not in a good mood for a minute one
minute one minute at a dinner table like
not cool
everyone's like even when I did plane to
the apps my energy was so high and
awesome and there was some stuff going
down that I wasn't pumped with and I was
like this next pitch I'm just gonna shut
down and the whole like everyone's like
what the [ __ ] burden like knowing that
there's some grateful first of all cuz
its power right like nobody has leverage
over me like I prefer it it's the
leverage so the burden now becomes more
of like don't do raw like even in your
full right don't have a macro like to me
I'm never gonna feel bad about
blindsight like you're fired
what the [ __ ] or like yo I don't want to
work with you like that anymore or like
you know what you're asking too you know
like people ask ask ask ask ask Emma
smile like you know what Matt like now
what what are gonna do about it because
I
leverage what I think I'm doing with it
is just trying to be more conscious I
don't I don't want to sandbag people
there's a fine line but you know look
everybody's a big boy girl and you
expect people to you know when you
internalize it like what we're talking
about right now what you're doing is
you're hoping the other person
recognizes how good it is and with that
value they're getting yeah and why do
they keep asking for more inches so
don't feel bad for the person that's
taking too much and hasn't figured out
how to do it I just want to be the best
version of myself that I can be you know
that's it that's kind of how I think
about it you know but yeah how'd you
guys meet like how does it start
we we all know you are honestly I'm
grateful for that for real man long
story like the long long story short we
actually been stopped by Southwest
without introduced by a gentleman by the
name of Mike Shehadeh but I don't
remember because unfortunate it was not
just that you know that's that world
what was actually a melee like ASAP mob
was fighting and you know I had we've
got rest his soul and so I like my like
fatherly leader instinct was to run to
see what's going on but then fast
forward a year later he was coming to do
some content with all deaf digital and
he just he killed it and then we met
like probably riot wasn't on the shoot
but we met right after this shoot and
then he just was that I was just
consider it was kind I'd like I like the
music I don't he wasn't like in the
apologies advance like even worked on
any of those records yet we just kept in
touch he came back to do another piece
of content with us and crushed it right
crushing it for real he and I found out
he actually came down from Oakland to LA
on a bus and I was pissed at my team
because I was like yo you could have
just flown him right but he came you
came in the same thing yeah I came in
that day took a bus and then well I
could be around those artists and then I
took a bus my drive yeah and then like a
couple months later he was like yo I
want to sit down didn't even ask like
for me to manage him but we just kind of
hit it off and I saw something there
then I had to take I had to do one more
thing on my checklist which was to see
him perform I saw him perform it was
like he put his own headlining tour
together called the longer tour December
2016
yeah and then after that man it was like
coefficients oh that's okay it's funny
the bus story is super interesting I
like um I've been thinking a lot about
like humility and hunger you know I like
putting letters together I like the
passion and patience thing really worked
for me so like the other day I was like
that's just real humility and real
hunger right yeah
I'm really works know he mean he was
hungry I could see it in his face too
because when I thought about what people
are hungry and fancy yeah that's right
no no no no well no and people are
humble and passive but if you ever if
you have humility and hunger he
definitely had I mean afterwards I
thought about how this guy's going back
to Oakland and he just come from Oakland
on return like how the thighs
performance would have been you know and
sure like this is after the fact right
but I was like yo you killed it like who
are you you know and that's kind of how
I felt
talent and I felt
Talon you know I mean yeah it's Alan
it's talent so we need real talent if
it's if it's parented right if the
environments right I think real talent
comes
I think humility naturally comes with
talent I really do well I think people
are confused I think it's the reverse of
what people think because if you if you
have talent and you're self-aware about
it you actually are humbled by it and
more importantly you feel like whether
it's inevitable or you're just patient
with it yeah like like you know I watch
people say it's just a matter of time
and it's like fake bravado like I see it
every day just a matter of time like
every day and social especially right
like just a matter of time before I but
it's it's fake yeah and then I see the
version of just a matter of time and
it's taking a bus I'll do anything still
that's what I really like about humility
is it's the core to the longevity
because you never I just will never go
to that other spot you know I'm just
gonna stay in this Lane it's real cut
like no Matt like I hear and see
everything that's happening with me I
just almost merely don't accept it you
know yes I'm unable to like it you know
and the people closest to me like my
assistants my babban or D Trog like
there's always something that I do that
I can see through their eyes them saying
like why is he doing that it's what do
you say that because it's when it's when
you say that because I've been trying to
pinpoint that emotion for a very very
long time probably like the past six to
seven months whose needs have been
happily happening you know repeatedly
and I think when we sold out Los Angeles
which was our first time I was selling
out the show Los Angeles we've done
times in silence we sure and how many
people always do younger than you go
ahead we I've been in a position where
I'm opening for our
at that level sheriff on a consistent
amount of basis so when that was
happening and everybody's just like
celebrating and you know obviously I'm
taking this moment in but there's always
that part of me that's just like it's
almost like there's a big Delta between
300 and Madison Square Gardens yeah
right for me to like I get it man yeah
but it's also like but it's also like
this very is this you feel so grateful
for something happening that it's almost
that it's almost like you don't want
wanted to get to your head it's human
Lillian hunger man yes you got a
humility to be like wow this is amazing
but you're hungry and thinking like you
know what's better than 330,000 yeah
like to me like it and listen man it's
gonna get more and more intense like
where I'm sitting right now in my life
culturally financially like impact it's
very high like I know where I'm at and
man I don't feel any different than I
did the first day I like get a flea
market when I was 14 it's crazy it's
crazy it's almost like something is
keeping me in a bubble outside of all
the admiration and success I don't know
what else to tell you
it's humility and hunger like I'm
humbled by it I don't take it for
granted I you know I don't think I'm
special like I think it's part of the
output I think my parents are special I
think my circumstance was special and
I'm just still so hungry yeah you know
and I look and and I think if that's
foundational I think you know you know
there's I don't know who they are but
somebody won four Grammys right and did
a show to days earlier to 81,000 and
felt the same way I feel right now or
you feel right now mm-hmm
you know I don't know a good point of it
right come to that type of you motion
yeah like if it's there it's there right
like it doesn't like you like I don't
know like I don't there's nothing I've
seen I've never been like you made it or
like like I'm always like humility I'm
like cool like night lion or a cover of
magazine or somebody cool dm's making it
out yeah I'm like yeah I'm like you know
this is deaf but still there's something
else there's never been anything like I
also think what's great about that is
that on because it's also really in love
right so like love doesn't really have a
price so it doesn't matter what it is
that you feel like you can attain you
know 20,000 buildings and you know sell
out as many concerts and win 85 Grammys
and you know be respected by their peers
and do all the coolest things in the
world but the love of what you're doing
is immeasurable there's no price tag to
it so it's also unlimited yeah writers
like I think that's the thing for me
right right it's unlimited like if there
is no it's not it's not even to your
point of measurability there is no
finish line I mean for me it's impact
right like there is no like what I'm not
gonna get the seven point eight billion
people like the Pope doesn't do that
Jesus Christ doesn't do that it's
Muhammad Ali didn't do that Gandhi
didn't do that Martin Luther King didn't
do like you're not gonna get to
everybody so to me it's almost like well
let me try
like so like like meaning meaning
meaning you know like I again it's about
self-awareness like I laugh right now
I'm laughing because I know that's on on
film and people are gonna watch that be
like what this guy's [ __ ] like the ego
is unbearable it I think people are
confused it's it's the reverse it's if
you live your life in a way like that
you know it's not that I expect to be on
that pedestal or to be very frank or
even want that it's that like why not
bring that much good yeah that's right
you know to me to me why not
what's the collateral of that ambition
cuz that's my life my life is gonna be
the collateral of the ambition to make
that kind of impact than have that kind
of legacy yeah that's what my day-to-day
is and what's really interesting for me
is unlike you and others I didn't grow
up doing something that made me think or
aspiring to do something that made me
think I could have that kind of impact
that's the great misunderstanding of
this amazing time is I pre-internet
would have been a good businessman
affected the thousands of 5,000 people
that worked with me and probably just 87
to 92 that worked close enough with me
my family my kids and I would have
called it a day
because I didn't do music or politics or
you know write novels or poetry you know
I wasn't doing art but which is how you
actually get there but I feel like how I
build businesses and things of that
nature is that it just we didn't live in
a world where that was document if I
think I've been spending a lot of time
looking at entrepreneurs in the 1800's
they made so much of the good impact in
our society like in the days of Kings
and like early countries being a stat
like you know it's funny I've always not
liked
narrative of businesses have a
responsibility meaning like not how the
Republicans or Democrats looked at it
some of it was to [ __ ] and just for
the money
and others was too altruistic and not
practical but I have been trying to find
that middle zone of like what's
happening with me and now spending a lot
of time on it but like it's really cool
to think about this conversation in a
macro meaning something's clearly
happening where the level of
conversation is just going in the right
direction yeah and I think it has to
overall you know just coming down to
especially coming down to like Howard
how we're eternally feeling and that's
why you know that's what I try to
accomplish with my last album apologies
in advance and what we try to accomplish
with our with our label and our company
wise though it's really sparking a
conversation so that we can change and
also alter perspective you should put
out more content that isn't music yeah I
agree I think that is the gateway to
your unlock if I music talent and put
out an album right now it would do real
well I you know this audience I think I
think you know not knowing how you
create music you know a lot of times you
guys know this I know like I'm always
like more music more music mainly cuz
that's one outlet I think just a general
thoughtfulness of your demeanor I think
you should do more of what I do I think
you should do like a 30 minute call-in
show where people just call in and ask
you questions like I do
Wow yeah I just think that you're you're
interested in vibe towards other things
that I think are important in the same
way that if you look at the genre of
hip-hop
people were just hip-hop artists and
then they became culturally relevant
individuals businessmen and women I just
think that you have white space to have
a different conversation with your
audience
oh great so now you've got some homework
yeah myself you know it's just yeah I
just think it would be interesting to
see if you went there I think you should
I mean he had put an email address in
his profile on Twitter and he's like hey
if you're going to some [ __ ] 7 me an
email and he legit was going through all
those emails so I mean if but being able
to do that I mean I think it's I think J
but I used to do that from 2007-2011
that's all I did
and then I've made it more outwardly
because what I realized is cool I could
answer that kid's question or that
grown-ups question but it was a one to
one thing meanwhile 30% of my audience
was dealing with the same [ __ ] yeah I
like to call if I do a lot though I'll
take that stuff that's what I think so
too I think it will be impactful because
I also think it's good it's a good
content it is you put that on YouTube
you put in a podcast you put on Facebook
and Instagram and you know you're just
building an authentic like all it comes
down to is relationships and there's a
lot of ways to have relationships you
know I'm just I just really I I feel
like I'm going through with my business
content and personal content something
very similar to like putting out a hit
album that like reached people it's very
true
animals 300 people that came to the show
wasn't like a normal 300 like of the
videos I've seen the crowd is going like
they think you go so deep with your fans
yeah cuz your give you put your heart
into it you're going so much deeper than
a lot of other working so what's
happening now um right now we're post
apologies innovative so you've been
releasing records working on another
record that's slated for sometime later
this year don't want to you know build
on that aspect I'm possibly planning
another to do right all right everything
and then what is your do you just like
it randomly hit you just start writing
or you like have a set regimen or what's
funny is I usually write all the time
and they always writing young always
writing usually when I'm creating
records I usually create director first
so I'll start by producing I also
produce all of my content so my last
album was entirely produced for myself
and I'll just start writing and then
we'll create the actual message and
formula around it as we were getting
halfway into the album every album I do
every body of work I have has to come
with something that you could take away
in news this it has to you know that's
my brand that's what wives up stands for
is changing perspectives and opening the
conversation so that comes first and
then a music music is justified I really
really think you should do Q&A man my
point of view I took a very different
turn once I really made it about them
even more I got all sorts of things
going through my head and I'm real quiet
with myself and I've unlimited content
but when you're answering questions when
you're it's in three or four questions a
day five seven nine three sixteen you
are you're in listening mode and you
have a different level I have such a
different level of pulse
than everybody because I'm listening
people just see the output of me talking
they don't see my 24 hours yeah
Yeah right they see me interviewing
somebody Gary you're always talking
you're always talking like no no I'm
always talking when you're seeing me my
other 16 hours a day are me listening
amazing reflecting and then they're only
seeing the output that's right people
will always want to just got a better
pulse it's you know it's things you
couldn't even imagine it's a kid calling
in telling you they're stuck on a drug
because they're really just anxious and
them using a terminology to a drug
you've never heard me just just a slang
term I don't know it's to say just a
slang term yeah no that's no I think
it's good to know what's out there I
mean I'm a little bit older but like
when I met somebody like Mike boy like
god knows how many years ago I was like
[ __ ] he really knows what the [ __ ] is
happening you know like he's paying
attention that's right like all these
are 10th Street right yeah
ear to the street and I'm like okay cool
you know what skip hop that lunch calm
like I'm like what like I haven't heard
of half these people half of these
people that I've gone to all these other
sites while whole thing who were like oh
cool yeah I saw him I saw the gun or saw
them in the fact you know wait a minute
how would I pay attention to your short
got your ear the streets you know and I
like that discovery I actually know I
love that and and it's huge in finding
that's a huge in this world I think the
closest thing the even closer to that
version once on the artists side is
one-on-one interaction with the audience
I got a bounce
bro thank you very much it's really
pleasure man I wish you nothing but the
best
so my salute oh yeah
[Music]